it was an awkward moment should prime
minister justin trudeau extend his hand
or stay in his spot
patron who owns the most famous nose in
ukraine let trudeau know his choice
stunk much to the delight of one of
canada's foremost dog trainers he
thought he was loaded
trudeau had traveled to kiev to offer
canada's support in the war against
russia he left having been upstaged by a
jack russell terrier funding for
demining operations
even if the dog barked at me we're
helping fund that
but patrol whose name means cartridge in
ukrainian is no ordinary dog he works in
the northern city of triniheav which was
pummeled by russian forces for over a
month and while the russians may have
left the city is no less dangerous
scattered amongst all the rubble there
remains a significant amount of
unexploded ordinance
that's patron's specialty since the
start of the war he's been credited with
detecting more than 200 explosives the
dog working in theater has got a lot of
explosive odor all over the place
and
it takes a lot of work to clear the
dog's head to look for
a source of an odor rather than just a
fringe odor sid murray who's been
training dogs for over 25 years and
helped demind bosnia and kosovo says
it's hard enough to do in a controlled
setting
finding explosives in an active war zone
is remarkable given what patron has done
it's no surprise he's gained a fan base
who have taken to knit plushies of the
two-year-old others have posted
paintings and drawings on social media
of our heroic looking hound with his
trademark vest doing what he does best
and that's where he'll return as a newly
minted hero of ukraine but he didn't
need the metal to know he was
appreciated just a scratch on the head
and a well-deserved good boy
mike dralet global news toronto